eventually I knew my competitors would
stop and I have zero plans of stopping
I just knew eventually their stomach was
going to be full
I just know eventually people were going
to be excited because it was enough for
them I just knew it and we would I mean
my confidence kept on one place I'm not
stopping and you're going to stop by the
way financial freedom Lamborghinis
Ferraris Ayase homes travel recognition
fame all this other stuff it doesn't
matter it's the same exact game skill
and I'm more excited about the game
today as I've ever been and I hope you
watching this have that same enthusiasm
that when you go out there make 138
thousand dollars in a week you're a
hundred times more excited than you've
ever been to get to work the next day
and build a business to a whole
different level I hope you don't go on
cruise control and give it you just come
back up better after no matter what it
is you come back with that fury with
that far and that's what it takes
[Music]
you